alexis poulain bonsoir merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france alors
tout d'abord emmanuel macron a donc tenu
sa promesse
il est revenu au liban en ce 1er
septembre mais au fond pourquoi faire
selon vous ah oui c'est vrai qu'il avait
promis le 6 août 1 lors de la visite de
beyrouth dévasté devenir le 1er
septembre on peut se demander qu'est ce
qu'il fait là et bien il fait comme à
son habitude du en même temps c'est à
dire qu'il réaffirme l'engagement de la
france au côté du liban dans la
reconstruction et qu'il essaye de faire
eh bien non pas de l'ingérence mais une
sorte d' aide incroyable au liban mais
on peut se demander vu ses prises de
paroles si ce n'est pas tout simplement
de l'ingérence puisqu'il parle de
sanctions d'ici trois mois si les
changements n'arrive pas et qu' il dit
qu'il changera de cap donc il est là
pour faire une étape
il est là pour le symbole bien entendu
vous l'avez rappelé c'est l'anniversaire
du grand liban il a il a utilisé les
symboles dans cette visite il a planté
un cèdre sur le mont liban il a
rencontré fairouz qui est cette icône
vivante de la chanson arabe
donc il est là pour bien ménager à la
fois la géopolitique française pour
réaffirmer l'engagement de la france
vis-à-vis du levant qui est une position
stratégique en méditerranée et puis pour
pousser les réformes de ce pays
avec ce nouveau premier ministre
moustapha adib qui a eu bien l'aval du
quai d'orsay et qui a su mettre à peu
près toutes les factions politiques
libanaises d'accord donc ça c'est la
première chose
l'autre chose c'est que cette visite
qu'on oui vous lisiez le président
français était là aussi apprend à
accélérer les réformes et sécuriser le
levant et les intérêts français c'est
bien cela oui absolument parce que
derrière ça fait c'est une autre
histoire la france et le liban
il y a bien sûr des intérêts pour la
reconstruction il ya aussi cette
campagne
victorieuse des mêmes vaincrons de 2017
avec plusieurs donateurs richissime du
liban qui l'ont aidé à accéder au
pouvoir en france donc un retour
d'ascenseur dans la banque dans
l'assurance du côté libanais il ya bien
sûr toute la diaspora libanaise
et puis les intérêts français pour la
reconstruction de les grandes
entreprises du cac 40 qui vont aider le
liban qui vont aider beyrouth à se
reconstruire
et puis encore une fois c'est tout un
système qui est en train de se mettre en
place et les libanais là où ils
l'avaient accueilli le 6 août comme un
libérateur comme un sauveur avec des
acclamations dans la rue aujourd'hui ils
sont un peu plus circonspect ils sont un
peu plus mesuré ils sont même plutôt
pessimiste parce qu'ils ont l'impression
de se faire voler leur révolution depuis
octobre 2017 2019 pardon parce qu
emmanuel macron indien a choisi de
discuter avec les forces politiques qui
sont responsables des crises et des
problèmes du liban et c'est pour ça
qu'il ya eu ces émeutes aujourd'hui il y
avait des manifestations place des
martyrs il ya eu des émeutes devant le
parlement
parce que le mouvement de la rue le
mouvement citoyen voit bien que derrière
la visite de madame accroc bien c'est
l'ancien monde libanais qui est en train
d'essayer de remettre la main sur la
reconstruction du liban avec des aides
qui vont être bien conditionné à des
réformes et ses réformes
on se demande quelles vont-être donc on
a l'impression un peu quesnel macron l
ambassadeur du fmi une truc à lui tout
seul et il va demander au liban de faire
des réformes
coûte que coûte pour avoir des aides
internationales ce n'est pas ce que
veulent les libanais je pense qu'ils
veulent
l'auto détermination qu'ils veulent
gérer qui lui a un vrai mouvement dégage
est aujourd'hui au liban
ils ne veulent plus voir les
responsables d'hier et aujourd'hui est
bien de voir comme ça ce dirigeant
français s'imposer sur la scène
libanaise crispe certains qui voudraient
continuer le mouvement citoyen qui a été
initiée en 2019 et au fond alexis
poulain cette venue au liban qu'est ce
qu'elle révèle de la posture que veut se
donner le président français est une
posture régaliennes oui alors c'est sûr
que pour la rentrée comme vous le disiez
il a choisi d'être au liban pour
souhaiter bonne rentrée aux élèves
français
il va éviter la scène nationale emmanuel
macron pour sa rentrée politique il va
utiliser ses prérogatives de président
de la république 1 c'est l'international
pourrait bien
rendre de la stature reprendre de la
hauteur pour aller à la fois sur les
terrains internationaux il ya le liban
il ya aussi le mali la syrie il y est
toute la méditerranée avec la crise
entre la grèce et la turquie
actuellement l'europe avec la dette bien
sûr ce plan de relance qu'on a tant est
qu'on ne voit pas emmanuel macron va
tout faire pour éviter la critique
interne la critique naturel en france et
laisser son gouvernement et jean castex
en première ligne et lui être ce
président français interventionniste un
peu présents partout parce que c'est là
qu'il va pouvoir remobiliser ses troupes
aujourd'hui l'arrêt met un peu éparses
on attend toujours de voir qui va
succéder à gilles legendre à l'assemblée
nationale et puis derrière c'est plus
facile finalement d'avoir cette posture
là que d'assumer les couacs de la
rentrée en tant de qu'ovide sachant que
les tests bien ne sont toujours pas là
que les masques sont obligatoires dès
qu'on a du mal à comprendre est que les
français aient bien sont inquiets parce
que le plan de relance est bien est
illisible toujours donc ça reste plus
facile d'être à l'international quand on
est président de la république que de
que de répondre aux angoisses et aux
attentes des français
et puis ça permet même macron de
souhaiter la rentrée sur une
continuation d'un air de vacances après
ses vacances en jet-ski largement décrié
par la presse internationale
merci beaucoup alexis poulain pour votre
décryptage rappelle que vous êtes
éditorialistes